>> I'M SORRY YOU AND ANGIE BROKE
UP.
ARE YOU GOING TO SIT HERE OR ARE
YOU GOING TO CALL HER.
>> IF I WERE HERE, I WOULDN'T
TAKE ME BACK EITHER.
I WAS REALLY A JERK TO HER.
I WAS SELFISH AND I WAS TOO
AFRAID TO BE VULNERABLE.
AND I LOST HER.
>> JOHN, THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
JUST TELL HER THAT.
>> YEAH, MAN.
SHE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
HEARING THAT.
JUST GIVE HER A CALL, BUDDY.
TELL HER WHAT YOU TOLD US.
>> HELLO?
>> HEY.
IT'S ME, IT'S JOHN.
[ BLEEP ] YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> NO.
[ BLEEP ] YOU.
WHY ARE YOU SAYING THAT?
>> NO.
>> STOP.
WHY ARE YOU SAYING THAT?
>> I'M FREAKING OUT.
>> STOP.
>> SAY WHAT YOU SAID EARLIER,
>> I'M FREAKING OUT.
THE BEING VULNERABLE THING.
>> SAY WHAT YOU SAID EARLIER,
>> [ BLEEP ] YOU.
THE BEING VULNERABLE THING.
>> OH NO!
>> [ BLEEP ] YOU.
>> [ BLEEP ].
>> OH NO!
>> WOULDN'T LET YOU IN IN THE
>> [ BLEEP ].
FIRST PLACE, GIRLIE.
>> WOULDN'T LET YOU IN IN THE
>> BAIL ME OUT, TELL HER I'M
FIRST PLACE, GIRLIE.
SORRY, PLEASE.
>> BAIL ME OUT, TELL HER I'M
>> HI, ANGIE, HEY.
SORRY, PLEASE.
SORRY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S --
>> HI, ANGIE, HEY.
[ BLEEP ] YOU.
SORRY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S --
>> OH MY GOD.
[ BLEEP ] YOU.
>> [ BLEEP ] YOU, LOSER.
>> OH MY GOD.
>> YOU'RE DOING IT TOO!
>> [ BLEEP ] YOU, LOSER.
>> I HATE ALL OF WHAT YOU'RE
>> YOU'RE DOING IT TOO!
WORKING WITH.
>> I HATE ALL OF WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT IS GOING ON?
WORKING WITH.
>> GET OFF THE PHONE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> ANGIE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
>> GET OFF THE PHONE.
GOING ON WITH THOSE GUYS.
>> ANGIE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
I LOVE YOU.
GOING ON WITH THOSE GUYS.
[ BLEEP ].
I LOVE YOU.
>> THAT'S MY EX-GIRLFRIEND!
[ BLEEP ].
>> ANGIE, IT'S ME.
>> THAT'S MY EX-GIRLFRIEND!
I'M REALLY SORRY.
>> ANGIE, IT'S ME.
>> DUDE, IT'S ON MUTE.
I'M REALLY SORRY.
>> OOPS.
>> DUDE, IT'S ON MUTE.
[ BLEEP ] YOU, [ BLEEP ].
>> OOPS.
>> WHY ARE WE SO OFF TODAY?
[ BLEEP ] YOU, [ BLEEP ].
>> SHE HUNG UP ON ME.
>> WHY ARE WE SO OFF TODAY?
WOW.
>> SHE HUNG UP ON ME.
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WOW.
>> VERY MATURE.
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> BLEW IT AGAIN WITH THE LOVE
>> VERY MATURE.
OF MY LIFE.
>> BLEW IT AGAIN WITH THE LOVE
>> YEAH, BLEW IT WITH MY LAST
OF MY LIFE.
GIRLFRIEND, TOO.
>> YEAH, BLEW IT WITH MY LAST
BY GETTING MY PENIS STUCK IN HER
GIRLFRIEND, TOO.
TOILET.
BY GETTING MY PENIS STUCK IN HER
JUST LIKE I BLEW IT WITH STEVIE.
TOILET.
EVERY TIME WE'D HAVE SEX, I'D
JUST LIKE I BLEW IT WITH STEVIE.
SAY, AICHEEWAWA.
EVERY TIME WE'D HAVE SEX, I'D
SHE DID NOT LIKE THAT.
SAY, AICHEEWAWA.
>> ANGIE WASN'T LIKE YOUR UGLY
SHE DID NOT LIKE THAT.
GIRLFRIENDS.
>> ANGIE WASN'T LIKE YOUR UGLY
SHE WAS AS WARM AS A SUMMER
GIRLFRIENDS.
NIGHT.
SHE WAS AS WARM AS A SUMMER
AS SWEET AS A SONG.
NIGHT.
SHE WAS --
AS SWEET AS A SONG.
>> OH MY GOSH, SHE'S ON HER WAY
SHE WAS --
UP.
>> OH MY GOSH, SHE'S ON HER WAY
>> YOU MOTHER [ BLEEP ]!
UP.
>> ANGIE!
>> YOU MOTHER [ BLEEP ]!
>> NO, NO, NO -- ANGIE, ANGIE!